>>> A NEW COVID VARIANT IS
SPREADING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OMICRON SUBVARIANTA.5 CAUSED
AN ESTIMATED 65% OF NEW COVID
INFECTIONS IN THE U.S. LAST
WEEK, UP FROM 54% THE WEEK
BEFORE.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO CDC DATA.
MEANWHILE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING ON A
PLAN TO APPROVE A SECOND ROUND
OF BOOSTER SHOTS FOR ALL U.S.
ADULTS.
WITH ME NOW, CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISER ON COVID-19 TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF ALLERGIES
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
WHAT'S THE MOST CONCERNING PART
ABOUT THIS BA.5 SUBVARIANT?
>> WELL, IT HAS WHAT WE CALL A
TRANSMISSION ADVANTAGE OVER
PRIOR VARIANTS.
AS YOU KNOW, WE'VE GONE THROUGH
BA.1, BA.2, DIFFERENT NUMBERS,
NOW WE HAVE BA.5, WHICH CLEARLY,
BECAUSE OF ITS ABILITY TO EVADE
IMMUNE RESPONSES EITHER FROM THE
VACCINE OR FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN PREVIOUSLY INFECTED, THE
ABILITY TO INFECT AN INDIVIDUAL
IS ENHANCED OVER PRIOR VARIANTS.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY YOU'RE
SEEING A REPORTED 140,000 OR SO
CASES A DAY.
IT'S LIKELY A GROSS
UNDERESTIMATE BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE GET TESTED WITH HOME KITS
AND DON'T REPORT IT.
SO WE'RE PROBABLY SEEING A
MULTIFOLD GREATER NUMBER THAN
THE 140,000.
DEATHS ARE STILL AROUND 300, BUT
HOSPITALIZATIONS, JON, ARE
TICKING UP.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING YOU DON'T
WANT TO PANIC ABOUT, BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
IT BECAUSE THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO TO BLUNT THAT.
I MEAN, WE STILL DON'T HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED AS WE
NEED, ONLY 67% OF THE
POPULATION.
ONLY HALF OF THOSE ARE BOOSTED.
WE NEED TO BE USING THE
MITIGATIONS WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
MASKING WHERE APPROPRIATE,
VACCINATING PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
VACCINATING AND BOOSTING PEOPLE
WHO ARE READY AND ELIGIBLE FOR
THEIR BOOST.
WE CAN DO THAT, BUT WE'RE NOT
DOING IT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING IT.
>> YOU SAID THIS NEW VARIANT
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
RE-INFECTION FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD IT.
HOW QUICKLY CAN YOU BE
RE-INFECTED?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT REALLY
VARIES, JON.
USUALLY IMMEDIATELY AFTER YOU'VE
BEEN INFECTED, WITHIN A PERIOD
OF WEEKS TO A MONTH, YOU'RE
PRETTY MUCH PROTECTED BECAUSE OF
THE IMMUNE RESPONSE.
SOME PEOPLE, AND THEY'RE
OUTLIERS, HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED
TO BE INFECTED WEEKS TO A MONTH
AFTER THE OFFICIAL INFECTION.
BUT MOST OF THE TIME THE
PROTECTION LASTS FOR A FEW
MONTHS.
BUT IF SOMEBODY WAS INFECTED
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO, PARTICULARLY
IF THEY WERE INFECTED WITH
OMICRON, THE PROTECTION THAT'S
GIVEN TO YOU AGAINST BA.5 WANES
AND DIMINISHES PRETTY RAPIDLY
OVER A PERIOD OF SEVERAL MONTHS.
>> IF YOU HAVEN'T RECEIVED A
SHOT THIS YEAR, A BOOSTER OR
YOUR SECOND VACCINE DOSE, IF YOU
HAVE NOT RECEIVED A SHOT IN
2022, HOW MUCH HAS YOUR IMMUNE
WANED?
>> CONSIDERABLY.
I MEAN, THE THING THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT
IMMUNITY AGAINST INFECTION WANES
PRETTY QUICKLY AND GOES WAY, WAY
DOWN.
WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE THAT THE
IMMUNITY AGAINST SEVERE DISEASE
LEADING TO HOSPITALIZATION AND,
UNFORTUNATELY, DEATH IN SOME
CASES, TENDS TO HOLD REASONABLY
WELL.
BUT IT'S SLIPPING.
IT WAS UP TO 90%, 80%, THEN IT
GOES DOWN TO 70%, 65% AND 50%,
THEN YOU'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU REALLY NEED A BOOST.
WHEN YOU GET OUT SIX OR SEVEN
MONTHS OR SO, WE'RE IN JULY, THE
SEVENTH MONTH OF THE YEAR, MOST
PEOPLE HAVE NOT RECEIVED A
BOOSTER THIS YEAR HAVE A
DIMINISHED IMMUNITY.
>> SHOULD PEOPLE BE MASKING
INDOORS AGAIN, GIVEN THE EXTRA
INFECTIOUS NATURE OF THIS NEW
VARIANT?
>> WELL, AS THE CDC MAKES IT
VERY CLEAR, DEPENDING UPON THE
DENSITY OF INFECTION, THE
DYNAMICS OF INFECTION IN THE
PLACE WHERE YOU LIVE.
AND YOU SEE, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP, WHERE JUST A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO IT WAS A LOT OF GREEN AND
SOME YELLOW, NOW WE'RE SEEING A
FAIR AMOUNT OF ORANGE, WHICH
MEANS YOU REALLY SHOULD, IN AN
INDOOR SETTING, A CONGREGATE
SETTING, BE WEARING MASKS.
IT'S JUST THE APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO TO PROTECT YOURSELF AND
YOUR FAMILY AND THOSE AROUND
YOU.
BECAUSE YOU COULD GET INFECTED
AND INADVERTENTLY, WITHOUT ANY
SYMPTOMS, TRANSMIT IT TO SOMEONE
PERHAPS IN YOUR OWN HOUSEHOLD
WHO IS VULNERABLE, EITHER AN
ELDERLY PERSON OR SOMEONE WITH
IMMUNE COMPROMISE.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WHEN
YOU'RE IN AN AREA WHERE THE
INFECTION DYNAMIC IS HIGH, YOU
SHOULD WEAR A MASK IN A
CONGREGATE INDOOR SETTING.
>> WHAT IS THE TIMETABLE, DO YOU
THINK, FOR APPROVAL FOR
AMERICANS UNDER 50 TO GET THEIR
SECOND BOOSTER SHOT?
>> WELL, IT'S BEING VERY
SERIOUSLY AND ACTIVELY
CONSIDERED, JON.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
LITERALLY EVERY DAY FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS AN FDA REGULATORY DECISION.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE MOST
QUALIFIED TO LOOK AT THE DATA
AND TO MAKE A DECISION WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WOULD EXTEND THE
REGULATION TO BE ABLE TO GIVE IT
TO PEOPLE LESS THAN 50.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEING ACTIVELY
DISCUSSED.
I CAN'T PREDICT IF AND WHEN IT
WILL HAPPEN, BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
GOING TO BE WITHIN A VERY
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME.
>> WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE YOU
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT YOU HAD
COVID.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING NOW AND WHAT
HAVE YOU LEARNED FROM GETTING
THROUGH IT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR ASKING, JON.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'M ACTUALLY FEELING FINE.
AND I THINK I'M AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMEONE WHO, BECAUSE OF MY AGE,
FALLS INTO A HIGH-RISK CATEGORY.
I WAS VACCINATED AND DOUBLY
BOOSTED AND I'M RELATIVELY
CERTAIN HAD I NOT BEEN
VACCINATED AND DOUBLY BOOSTED, I
MIGHT HAVE HAD A MORE SEVERE
COURSE THAN I HAD.
I WAS FORTUNATE.
IT WAS RELATIVELY MILD.
I'VE COMPLETELY RECOVERED, THANK
GOODNESS.
I FEEL BACK TO NORMAL.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN THAT WAY HAD I NOT BE